Let's briefly recap.
Power BI is an industry leader in business intelligence software in
no small part because the software is actually
three components in one: the Power Query layer,
which we use to extract, transform,
and load from a variety of data sources,
the Data Modeling layer,
where we build relationships between your data tables,
and the Reporting layer,
which we use to present the end-user with the data in a format they
can easily use to explore and better understand their data.
Versions of every one of these tools have been in Excel in the past.
Two of the three, Power Query and Power Pivot,
remain powerful tools you can use in Excel with
the same skills you'll be learning in this course for Power BI.
we need to take time to plan.
That planning has two main components.
First, collaboration.
Power BI models and reports are only as good as the inputs you have available,
both in terms of data sets and subject matter knowledge.
I'll be providing some tips on how you can work with
colleagues to make sure you can get the data right and how
you can go about making some of the more challenging judgment
calls when it comes to cleaning up or augmenting your data.
Finally, sketching your model is critical if
you want to be able to avoid putting all your energy into building the wrong thing.
We'll get some practice with this soon as well.
Throughout this course, will get
hands-on practice with all of the steps we've talked about in this lesson.
Being a data partner may not sound too glorious,
but the work you can do once you know how to prepare
and model your data, it's incredibly rewarding.